oh [ __ ] were back [ __ ] you told
uncle Joey forgot about unit yet
I was busy today there's some Monday's
you got motivation coming and there's
some Monday's you gotta do it on your
own that's part of the [ __ ]
life here yeah I'm saying but
everything's good we're back
it's Monday night time to see the devil
is young 18 hang up right the [ __ ] now
[ __ ] I don't want no [ __ ]
kazoo playing [ __ ] on here you
don't say
we've got more spots than ever okay what
did you eat today nothing
he ate that [ __ ] hummus again that
[ __ ] Syrian food run with the cactus
with the [ __ ] something was to happen
to see what you got attack the same
Sabrina
well it never changes the strangeness
well it don't matter cuz it's Monday
night and the best thing is you're
[ __ ] here and you quit [ __ ] it it's a
bonding type of night we got a lot of
[ __ ] going on to talk about so strap on
your seat belts [ __ ] fire fire
it looks like fauna [ __ ] look at that
it looked like wanna hit LaShawn it's
really [ __ ] tremendous it was sworn I
still got it
even on the Monday night you [ __ ]
[Music]
this ain't no smoke machine and this
made no vapor pen [ __ ]
this is lung heart and balls you
understand me Jesus Christ look at his
room if the fire alarm don't go off
tonight ain't nothin gonna go on we're
going deep tonight you better take some
of your grandma's chemo tablets cuz it's
over [ __ ] it if she loves the hair you
might as well lose your head to Kentucky
who gives a [ __ ] bald is back what the
[ __ ] Joey it's a Monday night [ __ ] in
beautiful Los Angeles we're in the
Voodoo Lounge aka the Sugar Shack we're
going deep into the [ __ ] murky
waters of the underworld Denver I love
you six sold-out shows nobody's better
than you you understand me nobody not
even Sinead O'Connor anyway ah I got
caught up with some tremendous [ __ ]
bong hits I just did I love you
[ __ ] I miss you I was busy this
morning I had to take mercy to the
dentist she's gonna kindergarten any
paperwork you know I'm saying go do your
thing
oh [ __ ] co Vaughn is here they're comin
[ __ ] I'm back like [ __ ] her I'm
back like the herp on a [ __ ]
Wednesday anyway stay black
[ __ ] uncle Joey here checking
in with you hoping you had a tremendous
[ __ ] Monday I had a great [ __ ] day
as usual Alabama I'm very sorry about
canceling this weekend I booked a
recurring role and I'm dying up here on
Showtime so I'll be shooting that all
week I'm excited I'm gonna miss you but
don't worry I'm making it up
and I'm going through national I'm gonna
make a stop in Nashville that's how I
roll [ __ ] anyway Joey what's
with the chitty-chat let's park up a
number if you're under 18 get off that
[ __ ] periscope you little [ __ ]
hopefully our fridge beat your [ __ ]
dog or something
you better run always [ __ ]
[Music]
we're gonna get smoked like that at
night you think gonna hey you in your
vapor frenzy should get all together
blowing smoke at each other's uncle Joey
coming at you direct [ __ ] ain't no
fortune cookies II I'm sayin
anyway that's it I got nothin else to
tell you [ __ ] tio wants coming
up the stairs we're gonna have a little
crack I like to here for a little while
then I gotta go home and hit the [ __ ]
hey I gotta be up early I got a shoot
tomorrow
Thursday [ __ ] don't worry about nothin
I'm covered but at least I'm getting
work they're thinking about me look at
the old ones the kid lookin do like a
[ __ ] periscope and snapchat
we don't wave [ __ ] around this
[ __ ] tonight if you haven't done
a [ __ ] Banga tonight you're lucky
[ __ ] day [ __ ] the old ones
here with coffee understand me [ __ ]
coffee you can leave the dolphin or not
to fire a llama go I said go away and
sit leave me alone but the test-drive
your cousin I understand you know more
and don't forget I got the Maluku stick
you can't put the [ __ ] my Luke on me
I'm saying I could put them a look I
knew you [ __ ] don't ever put them
a look on me anyway it's a beautiful
[ __ ] at night yeah I can't put them a
Luke I mean I got the [ __ ] I'm gonna
put it on my chain next week this [ __ ]
I'm gonna put on this one my door the
one my daughter made so I give you the
[ __ ] moment the horn and everything
you know I'm saying Lee come on oh well
let's do a bong video we're gonna get
rid of those spots
you got more spots get that [ __ ] down
sit down
don't sit on my glasses so low oh it's a
Monday night [ __ ] strap on a
pair do Vaughn's in the house we got the
second house by Pat Benatar [ __ ]
tremendous
crimes of passion hill breach your
brother's ass yeah I'm saying
Louisiana stop with a little shrine with
a little shrimp étouffée you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm saying you meet somebody's
[ __ ] with shrimp étouffée in it
tremendous where's Harvey Weinstein at
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
together
it's Monday night you know I'm saying
bang bang [ __ ] don't worry
about with shrimp étouffée only [ __ ]
real plays I gotta [ __ ] die them the
whole way I think I'm 2,000 miles yeah
bacon cheeseburger this [ __ ] food
unbelievable let's go bacon cheeseburger
let's do look up make sure focus show
them the spots on the forehead we're
gonna get rid of those [ __ ] spots
right now you put them on this is it
right here is the one that not on up
keep sucking keep sucking here you
expanded those ones that's the one
that's the one that's the one way back
all the way to your chest to your chest
all right oh [ __ ] this is what I'm
talking about
tonight this is what I'm talking about
Chinese Jim saying who the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with tonight boy
it's Monday night yesterday night at the
[ __ ] who'd aloud we got two reefers
tonight I stopped by the Russians and I
stopped by [ __ ] perennial yeah we got
the Paris og which is on fire and we got
this [ __ ] here this [ __ ] death on two
legs I want to give a shout out to my
man being Colorado who came to the show
a late 10 pounds of weed Wow but I
didn't know he was out there he didn't
let me know so nobody knows not oh yeah
we're going deep [ __ ] no edibles but
[ __ ] the reefer of death oh and
cheeseburgers Jim saying it's not like
the floors just got clean oh my god no
no no some have been done it's where
they think Dolly's least I had the [ __ ]
with smoking tonight it's fresh from the
devil's batch you know I got this weird
song that one i jus is back he's back
and he's got ash don't worry about where
he was no names no locations you don't
say bring your [ __ ] magic don't
forget CMC where yo the magic chain man
my Cubans and you down in Miami boy gave
me some beautiful silver well I'll smoke
this [ __ ] here let's go deep with the
[ __ ] Megadeth oh well you're a real
gut cook eat with that long history a
[ __ ] in the ass then let me be oh
[ __ ]
that's okay let's do this [ __ ] my
[ __ ] you ain't doing nothing
you're watching The Bachelorette walk it
off like a [ __ ] Mook the Lord
Uncle Joe is in your [ __ ] living room
get your [ __ ] together break out your
bunks let's do this [ __ ] Co bond is here
drove in [ __ ] traffic come off Asians
like an Asian you know I'm saying
gotten off Asians like a [ __ ] Asian
anyway
let's smoke a little bum oh and get this
party started
this is the [ __ ] right here oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] my ears are [ __ ] ring I swear to
God my left is [ __ ] good tomorrow
[Music]
yeah this is yours this is you oh you're
such a wimp with weed I've never smelled
like this I don't know how to describe
this smell it smells like my nuts just
get ready and open don't worry bud
are you giving me now we now know I gave
him some peewee lesbian they get rid
aside feed and the foot fell in there
and I took it on there just a little pre
out of blood so I saved it LAPD where to
we set it on tape and then we [ __ ]
smoked it you [ __ ] up dog we got
[ __ ] up
[Music]
some of that morning urine triple bra
and
[Music]
my scope brothers do it no [ __ ]
around this is you suck it there's a
good bomb come on let's do let's do this
bro there you go there you go that's the
one of this [ __ ] reefer speaking of
reefer I took four [ __ ] Swiss grizz's
last night lemon they some I took a [ __ ]
this afternoon it had to be 40 50 50
inches Oh dark rich butter smelt [ __ ]
horrible either open the back door for
the candle and [ __ ] Febreze
I had to open the door [ __ ] catch her
running away from the backyard that
swish-swish works I can't wait to see
what happens after a week I'm poppin for
them tomorrow you understand tonight
before I go to bed ya know with a little
apple tonight to really push it out my
mother did that best Deano you them
saying hey that's how we do it a little
[ __ ] apple for those swish Chris's
I'm gonna [ __ ] my [ __ ] everything I ate
the last 15 years that's how you do it
done yeah no you do when you're 20 you
eat all that dumb [ __ ] yeah and if
[ __ ] cars you up that shits in your
system good this is always a good
[ __ ] time especially a Monday night
is the way to start off whenever the old
ones in the room you know shits gonna
happen you know it's so funny how now
you can see the upcoming stars and you
can see him now it doesn't take a genius
nut you're the next generation you
[ __ ] deem that Rizzi you know you
could just see that every year you get
stronger
[ __ ] Burke crisis taping specials for
Tom Segura stay for this third special
it's like a [ __ ] league man and you go
from the minor leagues to the combatant
252 back into 82 back and 300 next you
know you won the World Series
what's the World Series whatever makes
you happy
yeah whatever level makes you happy you
know I'm saying but at least you put the
[ __ ] time in it's time for a [ __ ]
bond enjoy right if I hell is for chip
there we go [ __ ] got a little
[ __ ] will build your although for you
[ __ ] old-school
this is it [ __ ] it's been the
overall go baby
it wasn't [ __ ] around
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] my ears a [ __ ] ringing is
the Reaper death here we go
this is the way to start off a week
whether you want to untie here we go
this oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
well [ __ ] if you deal with unsaved Elio
or what it's Monday night I wouldn't
[ __ ] the body if we weren't gonna go off
the rails
tonight you understand me write your
goals do your push-ups go to youtube.com
slash c / Joey Diaz Bo Vaughn
uncle Joey and the [ __ ] you're
in for a good [ __ ] night plus we got
the acid we got in Denville you know I'm
saying so what we buy this smoke already
by mistake you know we don't [ __ ] around
Nayak you're almost sold out we're gonna
add a second show probably I'm letting
you know now don't complain to me later
I'm not going back to New York till
[ __ ] November so get it together
anyway that's it and that's that uncle
Joey loves you go to youtube.com slash
what see / see that get the ass is
starting to hit me /c / Joey Diaz for
[ __ ] more details and we'll keep this
party alive thank you very much for
supporting go give somebody ugh your
[ __ ] tell him you love him make that
date